I have been a lying German bitch.
Because I will be freeing the serfs...
Today!
And yes, I yelled that bit for effect. And
yes, you will pay them a wage and they will
buy goods and services and create another
economy, and they will strive for more and
invest themselves in Russia. And the filthy
stain of serfdom will be off your hearts.
And unfortunately, you may actually end up
richer. But I actually don't care whether it
costs you, it will be done. And there's no
amount of threat or spittle that you can aim
at me that will change my mind on that.
Get used to the future, gentlemen.
Because it's coming.
I wanted to talk to you.
Firstly, meet Coco Ottina.
This is my court and my rules!
You f****** kill Tarzinski, didn't you?
I did. And felt bad about it.
This random violence is not the way of my court.
He called me dickhead.
That is your answer? "I killed a man because
he called me dickhead."
Do you hear how that sounds?
Sounds perfectly logical.
Violence is not the answer to everything!
In this court, it is a language that everyone understands.You will not get far if you do not come to terms with that.
Fine.
Guards!
Beat the f*** out of him.
Funny. You're a witty creature. At times, the
point is so slight. One almost does not-
What the f*** are you two doing?
Oh! Oh!
Help, and you will be shot. My husband and
I are busy discussing an issue.
Can you hear me now?
I wanted to talk to you about the party last week.
Sorry.
The, um...
Are you reading?
Galileo. It's interesting.
Right.
What is your topic of concern?
The events following the party.
The fight between Volkov and Yakov where
Yakov bit Volkov's nutsack off?
No.
Your tongue on my bud.
Huh? I recall it. Yes.
What of it?
I just don't want you to get the wrong idea.
In what way?
In what it meant. I'm a busy empress with few
activities beyond my work, and a line between
me and the court that must be preserved to
maintain my power. And I was also very hung
over with a terrible headache. So, you seemed
the most efficient way to get my needs met.
You do not love me. You think you do, but you
do not.
I know my heart. I love you.
Stop saying it.
Yours is not a normal heart. You are not
capable of love. Not real love.
Selflessness for another. Tenderness. Curiosity. Intimacy.
You f****** love me and I love you. That is the f****** truth.
I don't love you. I will never love
you in the way you hope. You killed Leo.
You are a violent person with a terrible French
accent who, while he eats pussy well and
cares for his unborn child, is still a
mercurial maniac. I am fond of you. And that
is why you still walk the earth. Do not push
me to a corner I do not wish to be in.
I'm sorry to speak harshly. Let us put it behind
us. Agree to our accommodations as pleasing
for all, and finish me off.
You transition out of power and into
motherhood and Peter transitions back in and
it can be addressed through Europe as some
strange rumor. And I can get your sister the
French job back.
What?
We can all be just as I planned.
And you can be safe.
Darling.
You can play that boy. We both can, trust me.
You're staring at me blankly.
I'm just a piece in your perfect tableau. The
maestro of marriage.
You were born to be a royal wife.
You were trained to be a royal wife.
Be one and stop this and live.
Darling, your sisters can do it. Why can't
you?
Because I am not them. I'm better.
Oh. Oh.
Let's calm down. I can see a happy ending.
You are fond of Peter.
And why not?
Handsome as hell. He's a taste one wants in
one's mouth.
We can work this out, darling. I see a happy
ending.
Now I've raised it with Peter, and I can see
your way there.
You have gone behind my back. In my own
court.
To unseat me.
To save you from yourself.
You are always seeking for me to look at
reality.
Suddenly I am. And it is horrifying.
You don't believe in me. I've spent my life
trying to get you to. And you just don't.
Darling. Trust me. Your child will become
your empire, as mine did me.
It won't.
Russia is my child.
See, it's crazy statements like that that
make me worry about your mental state.
Recognize who and what I am. Or leave.
Recognize that you are mad and you need help.
And I am here to give it.
Get out of my palace.
Get out of my country. Go.